wird den ist ja der bundestag gewählt
was
eine sichere man ja steinmeier du nicht
ganz so germania scholz wird ich sollte
das bad am
rohrbacher
muss man ihm
bei cola und
multimillionär
engagement lerner war
blume
junghans cala bona
nationalsozialist
grc geht um die naju etwa demokratie
kita bei laminat
israel wetterfee die geoforscher knesset
lieber hapoel schiller demokratia
israeli
bei ferrari aber cash flow dort lachen
sie hat der bundestag
wäre das als mandela katri egbert sicher
und so schön bei josef
romano spadaro
schweiz build your music universal
ruin hannover wird er bei astoria einer
schiffskabine historie bett parlamente
germania
calik boss woman at t lmr
dammer lena seele der demokratie acke
davis
aroma combo einer
stadtrat lothar rohr
macabre danach ihm einfach mit gerrit
demokratie
clarity ist nicht immer
flachen das kkw roter weiter an die zu
wenig die event
plattform charité hat demokratie wenn er
in das schema schubert der neulich
schmorl nicole mich mal
mit roger
mosey krone showroom ist sie mag mich
galt als sie marschieren modelle
taktische koldo bernd hatte er oh herr
wahrhaben marie mal hallo da dort aber
eben die
krone schoss sechs boeing will im
western district bild die nicht versöhnt
farbig posmysz
branche million
programm ist prima kollegen muss sich
patrick hug mystery and besucher
vorträge über nottuln es so der shoah
sie mit zum zenit oder die lateinische
jahrmillionen demissionierte hrubesch
vor der oper im gang spaniens sie fuhr
sie bei ihm als hemmschuh
sie kann mich erinnern
einmal
erreicht wird ngo bach
mozart coal energy
ballett
josef in betty urviech zu sich ohne
schulische magath geforscht
lacht so will er wird aktuell
kolonne kulabas
jedem blickwinkel durchdringend die
botschaft übermittelt wie sonst wäre es
fassbar dass ein mädchen nur sieben
jahre lang kind sein durfte bevor es ins
konzentrationslager deportiert wurde es
ist unfassbar dass man eine mädchen die
kindheit traut ihm die familie nimmt die
menschenwürde
zuständigen engel dass sie es geschafft
haben das unfassbare zu greifbarer
erinnerung werden zu lassen danke dass
sie ihre persönliche bewegende
geschichte mit uns ja mit der ganzen
welt teilen für die erinnerung des
holocaust in kommenden generationen
die rotarier damen und herren die
entscheidungen dinges leben veränderten
wurden vor 80 jahren und sieben tagen
gefällt nicht weit von hier in der villa
wannsee als ich gestern vor der
prächtigen villa stand bereich sprachlos
ich spürte die unglaubliche diskrepanz
zwischen den pastoralen blumenbeeten
dem am horizont glitzernden see und der
grausamkeit mit der an diesem ort die
maschinerie zur vernichtung des
europäischen judentums
konstruiert wurde die das blut gefrieren
lassen die wannseekonferenz sollte die
verschiedenen bereiche konzentrieren
koordinieren um das übergeordnete ziel
des ns regimes zu erreichen nämlich
jegliche erinnerung an das jüdische volk
auszulöschen
im voraus geplante auf unerklärlichen
hass fossile vernichtung und menschen
morde wurden von einem regime das
demokratisch und rechtmäßig zustande kam
systematisch licht geführt wurde 80
jahre und sieben tage sind historisch
ein nichts und reichen aber nicht um
alle wunden zu heilen
viele noch
unverheirateten
werden noch mit sich herumgetragen für
die es nie heilung geben wird verehrte
damen und herren
die erinnerungsarbeit verbindet unsere
beiden völker ist das israelische und
deutsche
neben der erinnerung steht der aufbau in
diesen 80 jahren und sieben tagen ist es
uns unseren beiden missionen gelungen
uns aus dem nationalen historischen raum
heraus zu erheben um mit mut und
entschlossenheit etwas neues zu schaffen
zwei nationen zwischen tod und leben
entscheiden sich jeden tag erneut für
das leben
wache ich habe euch leben und tod
segen und fluch vorgelegt dass du das
leben er wähle ist und am leben bleibt
fünftes buch mose kapitel 30 fans 19
störung drei nationen die
eine außergewöhnliche reise zurückgelegt
haben auf dem weg zur versöhnung und
verfestigung der beziehungen der mutigen
freundschaft zwischen deutschland und
israel haben eine brücke gebaut sie
sehen die stärken und die bedeutung von
demokratien auf gleiche art und weise
und wissen um die unerlässliche
notwendigkeit gemeinsam an der bewahrung
der demokratie zu arbeiten immer wieder
tag für tag werden die beziehung
zwischen den völkern gefördert in der
welt des schaffens unter kultur der
technologie innovation handel
wissenschaft akademie
medizin wir haben zusammenarbeit in
sicherheit und nachrichtendiensten
geschaffen sowie wichtige und tiefe
kooperation zwischen unseren beiden
parlamenten ins leben gerufen
deutschland hat die verantwortung für
die sicherheit israels zu einem
grundpfeiler seiner außenpolitik gemacht
deutschland bezieht ganz entschieden
position gegen antisemitismus
auch wenn er sich in form von
antizionismus
äußert in bilateralen wie
internationalen foren beweis deutschland
mal für mal wieder seine moralische und
historische verpflichtung gegenüber der
existenz und sicherheit des staates
israel
unsere beziehungen sind von vertrauen
aufrichtigkeit solidarität und
gegenseitigkeit geprägt die es uns
ermöglicht den herausforderungen für
unsere beider staaten und auch für die
gesamte menschheit gemeinsam anzugehen
herausforderungen wie das krone vino
samt varianten oder die klimakrise die
unsere und die zukunft der gesamten welt
bedroht
das möchte ich mich noch einmal bedanken
bei der vorherigen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die ihre
lange amtszeit erst vor kurzem beendet
hat sie hat deutschlands stärke
verfestigt und sich unermüdlich für die
beziehungen zwischen unseren beiden
ländern eingesetzt vielen dank angela
merkel
mikroprojekte damen und herren der
bundeskanzler urlaub stolz der stadt ist
1 verlässt sich auf sie und weiß dass
sie diese langjährige tradition
fortsetzen werden dass wir gemeinsam
weiter an den beziehungen zwischen den
staaten und völkern arbeiten werden
werte damen und herren so viel wir
bereits getan haben mögen ist es doch
unsere pflicht immer noch mehr zu tun
letzlich erhalten wir die erinnerung
wach um das wohl menschlicher ewigkeit
zu sichern doch neben der erinnerung
müssen wir aus ihr heraus auch eine
vision schaffen dabei sollten wir die
hoffnung vor augen haben gemeinsam eine
zukunft zu planen die sich auf
gemeinsame werte und träume stützt wir
müssen unsere jungen menschen
zusammenbringen die generation der enkel
und urenkel die dritte und vierte
generation und all die generationen die
nach ihnen kommen werden wir müssen
ihnen den zusammenschluss von kräften
und köpft auf den weg geben zum wohl
einer zukunft voller inspiration eine
zukunft die auf den werten der
demokratie der freiheit und toleranz
basiert werte die israel und deutschland
teilen in unseren jungen frauen und
männern das gute im menschen sterben sie
davor zu warnen andere zu lassen nur
weil sie anders sind die
erich ernste mahnung des holocaust
wirklich ernste mahnung des holocaust an
den juden europas lautet
wie der nie wieder
die damen und herren vor 80 jahren und
sieben tagen sollte das jüdische volk
ausgelöscht werden seitdem ist unser
volk auferstanden wir haben einen
unabhängigen staat unsere historische
heimat den staat israel
heute wollen wir erinnern wir werden nie
vergessen und gemeinsam eine
vielversprechende zukunft schaffen
regelmäßig zum ende meiner ausführungen
komme möchte ich hier an diesem ort der
toten gedenken
dazu werde ich einen ausschnitt aus dem
kaddisch gebet verlesen das jüdische
gebet zur erhöhung ihrer seelen
werde das kaddisch aus einem jüdischen
gebetsbuch verlesen dass mir eigens für
den heutigen tag aus dem
holocaust-museum jad vaschem entlehnen
name ein gebetbuch das einem jüdisch
deutschen jungen bei seiner bar mitzwa
gedeihen tat am 22 oktober 1938 kurz vor
dem novemberpogrom auch als
kristallnacht bekannt kurz bevor das
leben das er hätte leben sollen an der
in deutschland herrschenden realität
zerbarst ein gebetbuch dass angesichts
der groll des holocaust schweigen da
stand endlich wie die männer aus stein
und stahl dieses hauses
ich möchte sie bitten sich zum verlesen
des gebets erheben kann der schweizer
in gewalt
die armee brachte
während ligmann gute wenn es mag eine
wirkliche
reform kreis
herford israel
ist man damit
wie monaco
bergwärts erstellung erwähnung wert
aber israel wegen
der
vielen dank
[Applaus]